trappes coignières ou encore magny les
hameaux voilà de quoi parlera le
spectacle j'habite hashtags saint
quentin en yvelines
une création de la compagnie 7 septembre
composé de témoignages d'habitants de
sky objectif donner la parole aux saint
quentinois
j'ai déposé un projet effectivement
auprès de la communauté d'agglo de saint
quentin en yvelines pour faire parler
tous les saint quentinois et
saint-quentinoise et pour essayer un
petit peu de comprendre ce que c'est est
ce ce processus de communauté d'agglo
qui a juste un nom et qui voilà qui est
divisé en douze villes et puis aussi
parce que ma compagnie travaille
beaucoup sur le témoignage un
questionnaire a été établi en amont pour
interpeller les habitants via les
réseaux sociaux
cinq personnes ont été choisies pour
participer à la création ils les ont à
coeur de parler de leur ville de trappes
j'y suis depuis hier disant tu as
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites at
rassure trappe depuis des années des
années
moi j'aimerais ak c'est justement tout
ce stéréotype aujourd'hui c'est plus ce
que c'était
c'est une ville où finalement comme
toutes les autres où on se sent bien les
trouver
super intéressant de pouvoir parler de
sa ville d'autant que j'y suis moi
depuis plus d'une trentaine d'années une
commune plutôt riche en événement riche
en équipements et puis surtout une
population plutôt solidaires les
témoignages écrits des habitants de sky
seront mis en scène et théâtralisée deux
comédiens sont présents sur le projet
pour accompagner le groupe dans le
processus de création qui a des petites
ça va jouer on prend des jouets et ouais
être avec eux les encadrer ouais enfin
au lieu de l'encadrement ce serait
plutôt accompagnement d'être là en
soutien d'être là pour aider à la mise
en scène si jamais il ya besoin de
conseils
le spectacle aura lieu le samedi 13
février au petit théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en partenariat
avec le musée de la ville